[Música]
comencemos por las gracias muchas
gracias soy el último que tranquilos va
bien va bien si se ha aguantado hasta
ahora pues ya lo que queda no será nada
ciertamente como decía ateo
soy diseñador
soy diseñador gráfico
y cuando dices esto
habitualmente tu interlocutor pues dice
ay qué bonito
hombre la verdad es que si hay cosas
peores cosas bastantes cosas peores pero
porque dice qué bonito
sino porque lo admiré no porque lo
entienda no porque sepa exactamente qué
es lo que estamos haciendo cuando te
dice haces carteles haces logotipos
haces dibujo dibujas bien yo también
tengo un ordenador yo utilizo el macro
prefiero al auto tipo de ordenadores no
y entonces no no cuidado el diseño es
otra cosa el diseño es otra actividad
entonces lo que vemos es que hay eso
muchos prejuicios mucho desconocimiento
mucho hablar cuando hablo del cartel
cuando hablo del logotipo cuando hablo
de la camiseta que compre que era muy
bonita me gustó más su diseño lo que se
hablando de los resultados no se tienen
en cuenta los planteamientos los
objetivos las problemáticas lo que
solucionamos
se está planteando en esos aspectos hay
una visión muy centrada en lo que es la
expresión y no la comunicación y eso
entra en relación con el arte es versus
diseño y entramos en una problemática en
el julián en una en un algo muy serio
pero eso luego hace 45.000 años poco más
o menos el ser humano
se dio cuenta lo pensó lo descubrió fue
la casualidad
aparecieron manos en las cuevas
aparecieron dibujos en las cuevas
y fue consciente de que eso permanecía
el ser humano es un ser visual
es radicalmente visual
es contractualmente visual sin la
credibilidad que estamos generando
respecto a aquellos que vemos es
altísima la respuesta de los estímulos
visuales supera al 80% los estímulos
visuales que nos llegan están en torno a
más del 80% y la respuesta respecto a
eso también está en torno al 80 por
ciento de aceptación de esa respuesta a
estudios analíticos si nos creemos lo
que vemos es problemático es muy
problemático creerse lo que uno ve y
cuando estamos en realidades virtuales
en simulación es todavía más
problemático porque antes se veía la
trampa ahora empiezan a no verse la
trampa con lo cual estamos en un
problema el ser humano es un ser visual
es una realidad
que descubrimos la permanencia de la
imagen que descubrieron hace 45 mil años
que aquello que hizo a alguien ese
alguien desapareció pero aquello que
hizo permanecía entonces descubrieron
que aquello que hizo
sirve para recordar quién lo hizo
y eso es muy importante porque habla de
la permanencia de la imagen y de la
trascendencia del ser de la
trascendencia del ser reconozco y fue el
abuelo el padre un antecesor que hizo
aquello que nos lo explicó que nos lo
enseñó que lo aprendimos fundamental
la trascendencia del ser es la
permanencia de la comunicación
hace 5.000 años poco más o menos
sumerios en distintos lugares en
distintas culturas sin necesariamente
tener ninguna relación desarrollan
escrituras y es el paso radical de la
prehistoria a la historia hay una
conciencia clara de que podemos contar
cosas y otros otros las podrán recoger y
aprenderán a lo mejor de mis aciertos o
de mis errores fundamental comunicación
hemos dicho que esa comunicación es
consustancial en todo de nosotros
perfecto pero claro no es en el mismo
tono no es en el mismo tono
como ha ido evolucionando yo soy diseño
gráfico soy profesor de universidad
estoy al frente de un colegio oficial
la actividad visual la construcción
visual del discurso es común todos
dibujáis incluso algunos bien
y casi todos os aclara jce con vuestros
dibujos con vuestros esquemas con lo
cual es útil no necesariamente
necesitamos una gran destreza hay una
actividad que es lo que estamos haciendo
a lo largo de los años esto que es una
actividad muy intrínseca la nuestra
propia existencia se ha convertido en
esta una generación visual más o menos
casual con aceptabilidad con unos
ciertos recorridos hasta ahí llegamos
todos con un alto nivel de implicación
emocional eso problema cuando tú tienes
que desarrollar una imagen respecto a un
dibujo realizado por un familiar no esta
es la imagen de la empresa la hice yo mi
hijo mi sobrino me la regaló hay una
inmensa valor emocional
problemática comunicativa entonces como
son ventas cómo explicas vamos a ir
desarrollándolo ese primer nivel es un
nivel de acceso pues básicamente
universal muy descuidado y muy
descuidado de la formación
se enseña a escribir y se enseña a
escribir con cuidado en el oriente y se
enseña a escribir además con intención
percibiendo la intensidad del trazo la
calidad del trazo la sucesión de los
trazos aquí se está empezando a enseñar
a escribir mal incluso con letra de palo
aunque son algunas escuelas ya ni
siquiera aprenden no directamente
contables en finlandia están recuperando
la caligrafía por algo será por algo
será no es precisamente su sistema de
enseñanza un sistema de lo más nefasto
que tenemos en europa a lo mejor tenemos
que recuperar la caligrafía y otras
muchas actividades plásticas porque son
herramientas de control de destreza de
seguridad personal no solamente de
dominio que a veces parecía de que la
cosa estaba como tenía que estar no te
des 13 de confianza eso que implica
oficio
tenemos que saber hacer las cosas aquí
ya no todos llegamos en oficio es la el
dominio instrumental
tenemos unos niveles de calidad
artesanía de control durante muchos años
el diseño ha sido una actividad a
esencialmente de oficio
empieza la profesión y la profesión
tiene un momento muy claro en el mundo
del diseño gráfico que es 1548
guttenberg desarrollo de la imprenta
good food y software pone en marcha una
industria especializado wood en ver un
técnico que opera un calígrafo y the
food
un inversor
el inversor que además era suegro de
software por eso la imprenta ellos se la
llevaron y le dio una patada guttenberg
y se quedó fuera con la fama y los otros
se quedaron con la industria del dinero
cosas que pasan organización tareas
profesión especialización aquí ya
estamos en otro nivel estamos en un
nivel diferente de responsabilidades
pero van pasando los años que estamos
ahora qué es lo que aporta la disciplina
esencialmente
transversalidad generación de
conocimiento
visualización y evidencia de posibles
resultados incluso en la conferencia de
antes de cuando super pongo dos gráficas
que hago veo la realidad si la
visualización es un elemento de
generación de conocimiento en las
charlas son texto es diseño la de la de
diseño y una de las cosas y las
características de las singularidades
que tiene el diseño también es esa es
que aporta conocimiento y se relaciona
con conocimientos dispersos con un
médico con un ingeniero o no en un tomo
logo con un fabricante de tornillos y
con todo eso generas un determinado
conocimiento vamos a plantear una
definición ya del ámbito disciplinar el
diseño gráfico es el proceso de
mediación entre la idea y la realidad
con pleno conocimiento importante pleno
conocimiento pensamiento crítico
experimentación análisis adecuación
pertinencia y sobre todo compromiso con
la sociedad y la naturaleza
sustancia
cuáles son los elementos característicos
permanentes
singulares propios invariables de todo
esto que estamos haciendo nosotros
porque no es que sean carteles o que
sean logotipos o que sean souvenirs
mucho de lo que hay en este museo es
diseño es expresión de la sociedad
me gusta generar formulaciones
matemáticas como estoy en entornos
científicos yo genero mis proyectos a
partir de formulaciones matemáticas es
una manera de darle credibilidad como
cuando digo que doy clases de biología
o condescendiente el que bonito
condescendiente se convierte en un
bonito admirador de agua pero como
aspecto científico es suficientemente
científico sin perder de vista la parte
humanística suficientemente humanístico
informar identificar e inducir esos son
las tres patas conceptuales robustas en
torno a las cuales todo proyecto de
diseño se articula que tenemos que saber
cuál es el emisor
identificar al emisor lo que el diseño
dice no es lo que dice el diseñador
lo que dice el diseño es lo que dice a
alguien alguna entidad alguna de alguna
circunstancia no es mi mensaje es el
mensaje de otro
informar por supuesto de algo estamos
explicando algo queremos contar fue un
buen diseño el de esta charla hay gente
alguien formó bien han venido a decir
que algunos recursos visuales se han
utilizado con suficiente eficacia para
que hoy haya personas aquí pues eso es
información que ha tenido un proceso
exitoso y todo eso para que precisamente
para que vengáis para que estéis para
inducir un comportamiento esa inducción
de comportamiento puede representar un
cambio de dieta puede representar un
cambio de comportamiento sexual puede
representar un cambio de relaciones
entre las personas puede representar el
respeto entre hombres y mujeres puede
verse presentar la comprensión entre
pueblos por qué pues porque hay
inducción de comportamientos también
puede ser manipulación y es un gran
poder con lo cual el diseño tiene una
gran responsabilidad
es disciplina es gran responsabilidad
si lo diferenciamos la inducción puede
ser eso puede ser
agresiva
qué es esto el proyecto
cualquier proyecto de diseño cualquier
actividad cualquier producto de diseño
en que se mueve se mueve precisamente en
los polos razonablemente a trier
atraídos gravitacionalmente por esta
realidad por los tres puntos focales
inducir informar identificar un centro
bar y centro doctor centro y depende de
cada proyecto se puede ir diferenciando
y si es un proyecto muy personal pues a
lo mejor se va a un extremo y eso es
complejo complejo porque es muy complejo
que es lo que lo solventa el proyecto y
el proyecto es algo parecido al
catalizador cuando estudiaba química me
encantaba cuando decían que es un
catalizador dice es algo que está que no
sirve para nada pero si no está no se
hace no funciona pero esto es magia no
es catalizador
pero pero no se gasta no pero si no está
no funciona no aparece pero no es magia
no es catalizador pues el diseño es un
catalizador si ésta funciona es eficacia
y si nota que pasa bueno funciona nos
eficacia el proyecto es ese crisol ese
crisol que une y entonces a partir de
entender el proyecto vamos a hablar de
arte versus de diseño y muy rápido
tenemos mucho en común mismos medios
mismos lenguajes similares formaciones
pero
diferente metodología
y una radical radical diferencia que es
retomó un esquema clásico de
comunicación que es pool conocido pisos
y emisor ganarle mensaje receptor que es
lo que pasa con el diseño un cambio
radical
el emisor el receptor el mundo del arte
pone su foco en el emisor es importante
lo que el artista ve lo que dice cómo lo
expresa el mundo del diseño pone su
punto focal radical en el receptor yo
explico para que sea entendido aquello
que quiero explicar puede darse el caso
que uno quiere hacer alguna actividad
plástica como artista
que interese que se vea la personalidad
del autor puede darse el caso peso
singular los fundamentales emisor
receptor y eso es un cambio entre el
punto de vista de la expresión y la
realidad de la comunicación en el arte
de la expresión es esencial en el diseño
la comunicación es esencial estamos
llegando
reflexión del proyecto no se puede ser
buen diseñador si no se es radicalmente
generoso y humilde aquí pierdo la mitad
de los diseñadores amigos
entonces cuando lo explico desde el
colegio y después ya no me quiero
colegio pero yo soy artista libertad
plena no sé qué dice pues no no es eso
no a lo mejor estás todavía en la
profesión y no has entendido la
disciplina a lo mejor tienes que dar ese
paso de crecimiento y ojo servir si ser
vil no la importancia de la letra para
un diseño gráfico porque forma palabras
y las palabras son muy diferentes
servir si serviles no cuál es la esencia
del diseño antes hemos visto la
sustancia cuál es la esencia del diseño
aquello que constituye la naturaleza de
las cosas
esta es la esencia del diseño el diseño
ayuda
[Aplausos]
[Música]